uh am i in presentation mode
did i manage to move to a presentation
actually if you you want to yeah just
use your presence
okay so it's really outgoing in a
nutshell i've never
first of all you can see the first slide
was uh prepared
am i with you
um
you know tal you kind of come in and out
i wonder if you turn off your own video
that might help
of your face um and then we just see
this lies i believe that's correct as
far as
you see the slides and you hear me
we see the sides we hear you
um but um you kind of come in and out
yeah because i'm not i don't know why
okay let's hope it'll be okay so this
you can see was prepared by pr people
not by me the next slides are not going
to be so nice so of course algorand was
founded by silvio mikali who we all know
um
the great things about the algorand
blockchain is that it's carbon neutral
it's very fast i'm going to talk about
that transaction costs are low
and um there is never a fork i'm going
to talk about that as well we have a lot
of programs going on which um if you
have uh students and people who want to
get into the blockchain space they offer
a lot of money
and you really can get wonderful funds
that also applies to faculty
and we just recently and this past week
launched the ace program aces uh
algorand centers of excellence and
they're intended for universities to
submit proposals doing research in um
blockchain this is a hundred million
algos um of course the amount in dollars
changes daily but that's um
1.7 let's say a 170 million dollars as
of this morning so a lot of money
they're also grand programs those are
very nice grants you can get up to three
hundred thousand dollars um for
proposing works this program is also
very highly funded
and if you're interested in starting d5
initiatives there's also a d5 fund that
you can apply to but a lot of money all
around for
things that are not um
you can actually do research on the
first two programs if you submit
something that interests uh algorand
so
now to go a little bit to the magic of
algorand to the protocol which of course
given that it's silvia who started this
you can imagine is a beautiful
solution to a problem
um first what is a decentralized ledger
maybe everybody knows but basically it's
sort of a blackboard that's standing in
the center of town that people can come
and write messages on they're completely
sorted and it can never be removed once
a message is uh put on the board but how
do we do this in uh in a decentralized
ledger so these are the blocks you want
to add blocks one after the other
and this of course to anybody who's
distributed knows that this relates
directly to the question of
byzantine agreement which has been
studied since the 1980s i want to say
something about blockchain technology in
general from the original bitcoin
solution and to more advanced protocols
what in my mind is nice is that it's
taking theoretical work that we've
worked on for 50 years and really
bringing it to the practice and
combining it in beautiful and
imaginative ways and i think that this
is the greatness of this area for people
like us who are researchers um in these
um on these topics
and uh so these were sort of byzantine
agreement is really a private yes uh the
slides don't seem to be advancing
um which one are you on do you see
byzantine agreement
uh no we are on the uh second slide with
sylvio's picture ah it is the best slide
but um
now are we on the right page
uh yeah it says byzantine agreement oh
yeah okay i i think i'm having problems
but
okay so basically these are sort of
private blockchains you can think of
them and the breakthrough that was
introduced by nokomoto is how do we make
this into public blockchains how do we
allow the whole world to participate in
order to maintain the ledger which of
course the byzantine agreement uh
protocols run in time at least
and cubed in the number of participants
so how do we do it if we're talking
about millions and millions of
participants how do we do such protocols
and the idea that
nakamoto has it's that we would do some
leader election and that was done via
proof of work
and basically there was a puzzle that
was put out and that minor guy there
sort of solved the puzzle and then it
was given the right to add the next
block to the blockchain
but the result of the fact that it's a
proof of work means that it takes 10
minutes to create a block the puzzle is
very computational intensive
for various reasons there are only 2 000
transactions per block
and this also causes there to be high
fees
of course because it's so labor
intensive the electricity consumption is
extremely high
and
de facto
instead of the idea was that it would be
a very decentralized system
the fact though it's very centralized
because mining farms were introduced and
and today it started that they're really
only three mining farms um two of them
in china so not very decentralized
and there's an additional issue which i
mentioned on the first uh slide that was
prepared by the pr people there's also
an issue of forking um that um sometimes
the the blockchain can split and then
somehow you need to converge
but
there is a potential for forking and in
fact the fact that there is a potential
for forking also causes this huge delay
between the time a transaction is
submitted to the time that it's accepted
because you want to know that no fork
occurred so it's a problem
let me skip this because i want to go
faster
so
the idea is and this is where this
ingenuity of silvio comes in is he said
why are we not doing something better
for the solving of the puzzle why does
the puzzle have to consume so much work
and in order to solve this thing he
introduced cryptographic certification
and as i said what's beautiful is that
theory again came into play and ideas
that had been around for a long time
were introduced for this
graphics certification and anybody who's
a little bit familiar with the
cryptographic works uh work uh
literature it's basically a verifiable
random function which was introduced in
a paper by mikali rabbini
in the um
late 90s early 2000s and incorporated in
a magical way into this thing to
substitute the pa the puzzle work with
something much faster
so here basically this is the
certificate here on the left this is
what is given out as a result of the
computation of the vrf it's extremely
fast
and um
you compute it locally and you can uh uh
yes tell your your slides are still
byzantine agreement oh my god oh my god
so you missed all my beautiful um
okay now we see fork in the road you
know what how about i leave it like this
and we can you see this
yes and then there is a presentation
mode okay let me let me do this quickly
just so all my artwork will not be lost
okay here you can see quickly quickly oh
look at this beautiful slide quickly
quickly quickly
the fork here you see the fork
and these two i skipped and here i spoke
about the fact that algorand uses the
sortition
and here is how the certificate is
created which is uh
via the vrf
but that was not the only problem that i
said in bitcoin that it takes a long
time to to prove the puzzle it also
takes a long
it still has the possibility of the fork
so then of course is
what do we do and we have these
solutions of byzantine agreement that
come into play again and the idea is
that in algorand you do both acros the
cryptographic sortation which is based
on the vrf which gives you the leader
quickly but then you also add on top of
it a very very fast byzantine agreement
to eliminate the possibility of the fork
so those two things combined and give
you the algorand
protocol
for
uh
the creations of the block
and what is the result of this
that you go down from 10 minutes to 5
seconds
you go up from 2 000 transactions to 5
000 transactions per block and you can
offer low fees
electricity consumption is
there is electricity consumption but
effectively nothing
and it also
eliminates those pools because what why
were the farms created because it's very
labor intensive so you sort of pull all
your resources together but here in
algorand actually every person who buys
algos
can participate in the block creation
proportional to the number of algos that
they have which is the idea of proof of
stake according to your steak you get to
participate and this eliminates uh the
chain and the forking and you have a mid
immediate finality okay
so now i want to say something a little
bit more researchy which i didn't
prepare in the slides
and the nakamoto model had
a new idea for um
computation sort of for protocols every
party speaks only once
and this helps against corruptions and
you don't know who's gonna be speaking
so if
um i'm gonna be the next person
preparing the block until i propose the
block i don't speak so nobody knows it's
gonna be me and this helps against the
tax
silvio took this thing to the next step
and managed to create a byzantine
agreement protocol where people need to
communicate
based on prior things that they had seen
in the protocol but he managed to
transform it yet again to a protocol
which each party speaks only once
and this was wonderful
but in the byzantine agreement protocol
parties don't have private information
so it's easier to do but in our group at
algorand what we did is we took it to
the next level and whoever knows what
multi-party computations are they're
protocols where many people participate
they also have private information
and even with this private information
we manage to give solutions that enable
each party um to speak only once and it
sort of started with very theoretical
work and now we're really pushing it to
implementing it and possibly getting it
on our blockchain in the future time
okay
and tell
you just have like one minute i'd say
i'll be done sorry thank you i know this
is super interesting though no problem
so um um so we have all these um the
blockchain has on top of it all kinds of
layers of operations and in our layer
one we can do a lot of things on the
blockchain already and our layer 2 has
actually very advanced smart contracts
we have a lot of things running with
standard assets which is sort of
something if you want to build on it you
create your own token and you run it
and
also d5 projects are starting to emerge
and if you want to get started to
building an algorithm here are links and
i will share this presentation and
anybody can have access to these things
and again i'm reminding of our big big
projects with all that wonderful amount
of money for anybody in the research
community um to access
that's it thank you
awesome
rebel
thank you that was great are there any
questions if there are questions you can
raise your hand or
you can put put in the chat a question
and we'll call on you
but i don't see any hands raised right
now
um but then again
um
let's see
yeah
okay thank you thank you tell um
i think uh prasad i think we can proceed
the next speaker is reena barney from
google
wasn't it someone else in the before me
um no
yeah yeah go ahead reena thank you
okay can you see this
yes
yes we can see it
and is it advancing fine
yeah
perfectly thank you
yeah so i'll be talking about what are
some potential data structures that
could be
uh used in the destruction
of the mind
so we constantly faced with sights and
sounds and we try to make sense of it
and make predictions and take actions
uh
and
is the mind like some single giant deep
network or is it lots of modules
uh how is memory implemented
so if you just meet someone over coffee
for a chat
um
you know how to remember who was a
person what was roughly talked about
and more importantly if we were to meet
the same person again how do we retrieve
that information about the previous
meeting
so that we use that for our next one is
that some kind of an
uh knowledge graph in our mind and we're
not looking for
physiological understanding but abstract
algorithmic understanding
so one thing to note is that if we close
our eyes we can approximately visualize
scenes and sounds from the past which
means that we probably have a sketch
store some sketch in our mind that is
uh approximately can reconstruct the
event and it seems to have this our
memory seems to have this great graceful
erasure property that means we don't
forget things suddenly but gradually
where we still remember high level
details and perhaps at a logical level
an abstract level we have many modules
in our mind
for example you can have something for
driving for hiking
for recognizing people for sounds and at
any one point of time we're probably
only using uh a few of those modules
like in you know meeting with someone
we're just using the speech recognition
module to under the speech and the
visual recognition module trying to
find people and output people embeddings
so more generally we might have this
modular network
uh which are connected by some edges and
at any one point of time only a sparse
skeleton of modules are firing and
producing embeddings for the next level
module
and when we want to sketch this we want
to essentially record which modules
fired with what values and there's a
very simple way of doing this using
subspace embedding so pretend for a
moment that all the modules are just at
one flat level of hierarchy like this
like thousands of modules and only a
couple of these are firing like the
person recognition and the speech
recognition one
with some nonzero values with some
vectors coming out of those
and to record this all you do is you hit
each modules output with a
random matrix a separate random fixed
random matrix for each module and then
you add up all these and you get the
final sketch and as long as the
dimensionality of the sketch is
sufficient to hold the information from
each of the nonzero modules you can use
that final sketch to actually recover
exactly which modules fired with what
values and this is basically the type of
sparse encoding and spots recovery
and you can think of each module as
outputting an object of a certain type
and the type information is being
encoded in a specific subspace or a
specific direction which is given by the
uh which is given by the random matrix
it's giving an object-oriented view of
the final sketch
and it maps events into sketch space
where similar events have similar
sketches so if i were to meet someone
again
uh it will probably get the same modules
firing with almost the same values so
we'll get similar sketches
and also it can be used to um
uh infer to learn new concepts for
example if i've never seen a tiger
before and if i start seeing a few
tigers then the sketch of a tiger in
terms of the previous level
modules will all form a small cluster so
when i see a new cluster it's time for
me to understand that there's a new
concept here and i need to allocate a
new module
so this essentially gives a sketch over
our life as we collect more and more
events we get a repository of sketches
which forms a knowledge graph and the
edges are just implicit edges which are
saying that these two sketches are
similar or related that's why there's an
implicit edge and there's a modular
network that is constantly interacting
with this knowledge graph and so if i
meet someone again for coffee i can use
this knowledge graph to retrieve the
sketch of the previous event and use
that to decide what i do next
so we get a sketching mechanism that
gives
sketches that are related similar if
they're
if they're almost the same events
and the similar events
and the sketches can be used to
approximately reconstruct the original
event but if it is the event has many
things like this if you see a room of
100 people and if you have a small
sketch you won't be able to figure out
exactly each of the people's details but
you can still recover average
information like where most of them
wearing black shirts or what is the
average height
of the people there it has this graceful
erasure property because it's a subspace
embedding so even if you chop off half
of the sketch you still remember high
level details uh you get this object
oriented view and the type information
where type is encoded on subspaces and
it can be used for um continual learning
where new concepts produce new modules
the way you get this continuous learning
thing is you have this lsh table of
buckets where you store not only record
sketches but you can also grow modules
that if you start seeing a bucket that's
being hit often then it's time to learn
a new module and you can have edges
bring the buckets based on co-occurrence
to get a knowledge graph
so we implemented a very simplified
version of this
as a neural memory that can be attached
to any deep network all we did was just
use an lsh table uh no modules within
the buckets and no edges across them
and just the contents of the electricity
can be trained and just that itself was
was quite useful in increasing the
capacity of a bert model for language
understanding task
so
uh just by attaching a small ten percent
uh um lsh table which is of ten percent
of the size of the whole network
we increase the amount of computation by
just one percent and we get
uh more the same benefit as you would
get by doubling the size of the birth
model
uh so in summary you know we have a
continual learning architecture and we
have a simple implementation of it based
on sketching and lsh and the other
references thanks
thanks reena thanks for the talk any
questions for rena
i don't see any raised hands so
all right
yeah
reena i have to i have to compliment
rina you came in you had four seconds
left okay
just a quick oh can i ask a quick
question i just can you put the links in
the chat because we couldn't click on
the
the link in the slide i think
for the references yeah thanks
okay thank you
sure oh thank you arena
thanks cynthia
uh so our next speaker is
alberto pozanko lancho from jpmorgan
so can you see my screen
yes
yes okay
oh hi everyone i'm alberto and today
i'll be presenting proving security of
cryptographic protocols using automatic
planning which is a joint work with our
colleagues at the j.p morgan air
research lab
so the motivation of this work is
multi-party computation which is a
framework that enables different parties
to perform a joint computation over
their data while keeping it private
this kind of protocols are increasingly
used at financial institutions but we
need to prove that these protocols are
secured
there exists a
some method different methods to prove
that security and in this work we are
trying to improve the security of this
kind of protocols using automated
planning
so automatic planning is a technique
that uses domain independent heuristic
search to find a sequence of actions
that achieve the goals from a given
initial state so for example in a map
navigation problem given initial
location how to reach the destination
the goal state
however planning can also be used to do
kind of the opposite so prove that there
is no sequence of actions so no plan
exists that achieve the goals from that
initial state
and for that case we we change or
initial state and now it will be the
information held by each user and the
parties that can be corrupted
and in the goals we will have that the
protocol needs to finish so work as
planned and that some security
properties need to be verified
and we will also have in the actions to
achieve the goals from this estate the
action that each party can execute so
each user and the server and also the
malicious young attacks
and after giving these inputs to the
planner the plan will return either if a
plan exists and therefore the protocol
is not secure
or if a plan does not exist in which
case the protocol will be secured
so let's focus now on the protocol on
this protocol privacy per serving
aggregation protocol
so in this protocol we have a set of
users or agents
each of them has some information that
can be splitted or decomposed into
multiple parts so for example here we
have x1 and his information can be
decomposed into alpha 1 and 2 and so on
so now let's see how this protocol works
in the first round the user exchanged
the information so x1 sends alpha 2 to
x2 alpha 3 to x3 and so on and it also
receives some information from the other
users creating this kind of metrics
in the next round of the protocol the
user sum the information and send it to
the server which computes the
aggregation
and by following this protocol the
server cannot identify
which is its user so basically the user
keep their data private
and in this protocol the malicious chain
can perform the following attacks it can
corrupt an user and therefore it will
know the information of that user and
also the information that user received
it can also corrupt the server in which
case it will know the partial sum of
each of the users and also the total sum
computed by the server
and it can also infer information so for
example if we have if the malicious
agent have access to these three pieces
of information
and the partial sum it will be able to
uh infer delta one by subtraction
so now let's see how we model this
cryptographic protocol and the attacks
in pdl which is a logic based language
that is a standard in the automatic
planning community
so in pddl we need to define predicates
that are the pieces of information we
are going to reason about so for example
in this case we
we use the noun we created a noun
predicate that represents that a given
share from an user is known by another
user we we also have predicates like
concor up that represents that a
malicious agent can corrupt that even
user and with these predicates we build
the actions that will describe the
dynamics of this domain in this case the
dynamics of the protocol and the
possible attacks that the malicious
chain can conduct
and this action takes the form of
preconditions and effects so for an
action to be executed some of these
predicates need to hold and after
executing the action some of these
predicates will change their truth value
so after describing the domain and the
dynamics of the of the problem we need
to define the problem itself so in the
initial state we will have that we will
be in the first round of the in the
round in the first row of the protocol
the users know the wrong information of
course and we also need to specify the
parties that the money is saying can
corrupt so in this case let's say it can
corrupt these three
these three users
and in the goal we need to specify
that the protocol needs needs to end so
the server needs to compute aggregation
and also we need to specify the security
properties we want to verify in this
case that the malicious agent cannot
know or cannot infer the information
from the user x4
and for the sake of time i want to enter
into much detail on the proof but
basically what we do is to create
problems with increasing number of users
being corrupted
and at the moment that the planner
returns a plan it will mean that the
protocol is not secure so for this
particular for this simple scenario the
protocol
is secured up to three users plus the
server being corrupted and this is the
plan that the there were trace that the
planner returns and is the plan that the
medicine could follow to infer the
information from all the users
so wrapping up we have shown how
planning can be used to verify the
security of cryptographic protocols
we have something that is quite cool in
the planning community that is that pdl
is a standard language and this is an
advantage over model checking where each
model checker tend to have the their own
language definition
and by leveraging on the spddl language
we can use a wide variety of powerful
planners that can usually
that are really efficient and often can
detect the unsolvability of this task
even without conducting any search and
in future work this is ongoing decision
one word so in the future we like to
compare against model checkers
my model improve other protocols and
check different security properties
so that's all on my side thank you very
much
thank you
thanks alberto
so next speaker is vipul goyal from ndt
research
okay can you see my screen
uh yes
[Music]
okay so hi i am vipul goyal and i will
talk about post quantum secure
multi-party computation uh i'm from ntt
research
um so so let me first talk about secure
multi-party competition
so here we have several parties
four parties here
and they each have a private input
and they are trying to compute some
joint function of these private inputs
so as an example maybe we have four
millionaires and they are trying to
compute
who is the richest among them without
revealing exactly their network to each
other
so
this can be framed as an instance of mpc
but
this is just a toy example but mpc has
many applications so for example privacy
preserving machine learning
uh or data mining and so on
so over the last three decades mpc has
been a very long and successful line of
research
and
initially for the first
couple of decades it was seen mainly as
a
theoretical tool
uh but over the last five to ten years
it has also been moving
from theory to practice
so i want to focus on the quantum analog
of mpc
so a natural question is what if an
adversary acquires a quantum computer
either now or maybe not now but sometime
in the future
so there has been a sort of a boom in
the study of
quantum computing and quantum
cryptography
so this is a very natural question uh
maybe the adversity is storing
all the messages in the mpc protocol and
in future when quantum computers become
more realistic maybe the adversary will
try to break and will try to sort of
obtain the private inputs
so the question is can we build mpc
secure against these type of adversaries
and
we call this to be post quantum mpc
and actually even before going to mpc if
you work in cryptography you might be
wondering about zero knowledge which is
sort of
even simpler than mpc it can be seen as
a special case of npc
so in zero knowledge we have approver
and a verifier
and the prover is trying to prove a
statement to the verifier
while hiding the witness
right so can we build post quantum zero
knowledge so let's say
the verifier is a quantum adversary and
verifies trying to learn something about
the witness from the proof
so uh at first it might seem like post
quantum zero knowledge or mpc might not
be very hard
right so
the area of post quantum cryptography
has seen very rapid progress over the
last five to ten years so for example
now we have lattice-based cryptography
which can allow us to do
all kind of beautiful things
so there are several simple zero
knowledge and npc protocols based on
sort of mild primitives or mild
cryptographic assumptions like
one way functions
or in case of mpc it would be
what is known as oblivious transfer
so the natural question is just just
take these these protocols and the
cryptographic primitive which you are
using let's say a one-way function
just use the post-quantum version of
that printing so just instantiate this
using post quantum primitives
so does this already work and the answer
is no
and this is a very interesting problem
quantum information behaves in a
fundamentally different way so for
example there's the no cloning theorem
which says that you cannot make copies
of an arbitrary unknown quantum state
so
just the way quantum information behaves
leads to sort of many of these protocols
becoming insecure
even if you are using post quantum
primitives to instantiate them
and if you are familiar with
cryptography let me give you a very
brief sort of example of what might
break down so in geo knowledge that mpc
we typically talk about simulators which
rewind the adversity
so what does a winding even mean
the simulator will take snapshots or
make copies of the state of the
adversary
periodically
and then at any given point of time
simulator can sort of discard the
current copy or the current state and go
back to a previous copy
this is how you implement rewinding but
you know you cannot copy arbitrary
states if the adversary a is a quantum
adversary then because of no cloning you
cannot make copies so you cannot remind
the adversary
in a straightforward way unlike the
classical setting
and this is not just a theoretical
concern in fact
there are protocols which are secure in
the classical setting but they break
down in the quantum setting
even if you instantiate them with
post-quantum assumptions
so in a beautiful work of waters in 2009
the first
post-quantum zero knowledge was proposed
but the progress on the npc side which
is a generalization of zero knowledge
was a little bit slow
so in a very recent result uh we were
able to build sort of the first
classical mpc protocol which is secure
against quantum adversaries so the
protocol and honest parties they don't
need quantum capabilities but
if the adversary has quantum
capabilities the security is still
preserved
and our protocol is constant round and
it doesn't use any trusted parties
if you use trusted parties then there
was some previous works already
and along the way
while building mpc we also sort of
initiate the study of
various uh interesting post quantum
primitives
so we study what is known as post
quantum coin tossing coin trusting over
the internet is you and i are not in the
same room but we want to flip a coin and
the coin must be fair
and
we initiate the study of post quantum
non-malevolent commitments
and there are many other technical
challenges which one has to overcome
so i want to leave with several future
directions i think
we are just sort of starting to scratch
the surface here
so a very natural question is can we
build post quantum mpc
with better efficiency or with better
cryptographic assumptions
or we can move to quantum mpc so in
quantum mpc
the inputs are quantum states and the
circuit can even be a quantum state so
let's say
you want to run shows factoring
algorithm
um
using an mpc right so that's a quantum
circuit
so can we build quantum mpc and there
are already a few works in this
direction but like less than 5 papers
and
another natural direction is we can
stick to classical inputs and circuits
but we can use quantum communication so
we are trying to solve an older problem
but with newer sort of tools so one
might be able to get better results by
doing this
and then finally
can we come up with fundamentally new
ways of building zero knowledge and npc
in the quantum setting uh so far all the
works are sort of trying to take the
classical ideas and trying to sort of
mimic them or transport them in the
quantum setting
but quantum information behaves in a
fundamentally different way so maybe you
know there are like completely different
ways of
uh of doing simulation and building zero
knowledge in a pc
okay so i will stop here
thanks
so next speaker is uh
elizabeth barton from roc 360.
hi everybody i'm betsy barton i work at
well i'm a i work with rock 360. i'm
going to switch gears a little bit
um and talk about some problems uh
relating to the u.s housing stock and
refreshing u.s housing stock
so this is
um this is a problem where the use of
technology is somewhat new uh so it's
kind of different from the other talks
that we've seen today
um but it's a very big problem
uh where technology is it's it's time
it's right for technological
applications
so i think the the question is so the us
housing stock is age
about 80 of us housing is more than 20
years old and about 40 percent of it is
more than 50 years old so big question
is how do we upgrade this housing in a
way that's efficient effective and
sustainable and furthermore
the fraction of housing with green
certification is very small most of this
housing is not environmentally
very well put together it's not
sustainable
and how do we
change that and um you know improve
the sustainability of the u.s housing
stack
so technology what is the role of
technology um i'm gonna just sort of
survey some things that we're doing the
problem is very difficult because the
market is highly fragmented so it's it's
the scalability of solutions to this
problem are very limited right now um
flippers house housing clippers work
alone or in small groups many people
sell their homes with isolated real
estate agents
there's some data available but it's
limited
um so the roles for technology in the in
the near and medium and long term are to
discover the homes that need renovation
understand what in those homes needs to
be renovated which is difficult to do
even if you're standing in the middle of
a house to be honest so it's a very hard
problem to do and you haven't walked
inside the home yet and then optimize
the plan the materials the labor and the
management which is again something that
really has not been done
to date
so outside the home obviously the place
we can get the most data is the outside
of the home so things like drone imagery
and
google street view and even you can
physically drive by a house if you're
trying to identify the houses that need
renovation
um so in these cases it's obviously
possible to use computer vision to
identify dilapidated housing from images
or roofs and outside and understand the
neighborhoods and make models about what
you think is going to happen to the
neighborhoods and what the economics and
liquidity in the situation are for
example
but you can't tell very much from
standing outside of the home about
what's actually inside of it
so this is a major problem um
inside the home you do have data
uh you the multiple listing service um
so every house that's been on the market
recently for the most part we have
images from the inside
um
there's a you know it's a huge amount of
data it's possible to use computer
vision to evaluate the
the inside the images from these houses
but there's a number of issues so first
of all this is a very different problem
from for example the object detection
problem
because you're asking what is the
condition of this property not what is
this object and so um
it it lends itself some to some
differences
um but the other thing is there's
there's like less tangible things about
is this an updated property is it modern
looking is it appealing to people these
are different different types of
problems than the standard object
detection
nlp so natural language process on
processing on descriptions in the mls
is probably the easiest problem i'll
talk about today
um because there are a lot of clues like
things being called a fixture upper or
point and charming uh
but the fundamental problem with the mls
data is that it offers you a very biased
view
um you're seeing what a real estate
agent allowed you to see right but it is
the most common thing that we have
inside of people's houses so uh you know
there's there's a lot of work to be done
in this area
but it has some fundamental limitations
another area um that i think is even
newer is the idea of getting data from
inside of the home in an owner-generated
way
can we convince people to give us data
about the inside of our home
once we do that we sell the same
computer vision problems um
with you know analyzing it telling the
condition is it up to date is it
appealing to people how big is it
um so
things like size obviously nowadays our
phones are capable of producing
stereoscopic imagery can we get people
to give this
to us from the insides of our houses
this is a much less biased view because
it's not a real estate agent deciding
what to show people
uh from the inside of your house it's uh
you know a person giving us a view of
this so this is a um something that
we're thinking about really hard right
now and also how to use computer vision
to evaluate what we see
um and then inside the walls even more
sort of further out but uh more
important so like i said before you can
be standing in the middle of the house
and you still don't necessarily know
what needs to be done to fix this house
um and you know for example you can walk
into an older house and think that it's
going to cause a certain amount to
renovate and then get one of the walls
down and realize you have a much bigger
problem
and for sure this happens all the time
so there are non-invasive imaging
techniques that we're thinking about for
example um lidar obviously not at
visible wavelengths um
they can see through walls and you know
it's another example of a nation
technology that really requires uh a lot
more development and a lot more work
but would be fantastic for use in this
problem trying to understand what you
want to do uh inside a home what needs
to be done
so the last thing i'm uh in just this
sort of survey is that the full
optimization problem
so
um most of you probably know when you go
to renovate a house right now uh
it's it's not a very controlled again
it's a fragmented process so you have to
con combine a lot of different things to
try to understand what you need to do
there's you know
what order should i you know there's
what should i actually do the
conditioning so what do i need to do in
this house and then there's the after
repair value like what does it make
financial sense to actually do with this
house
then there's can i get the permits what
about the regulations then there's
materials pricing and what does it make
sense to put in here and what's going to
be reflected in the after repair value
of the house and then green upgrades
what makes sense environmentally to
actually do
and there's the labor market which is
changing incredibly dramatically and
covered for example and availability of
someone to manage this project and
there's management tools and do any of
them give you what you want are any of
them scalable how well do they work
and finally the construction ordering
optimization problem
um
the you know what do i do and what order
do i do it in and how do i do it in a
way that manages the labor uh uh and the
management and it's just the management
so that the product is doable so that we
could tell if we're on you know on
budget is it on time etc so this is
actually a huge optimization problem um
that we're making some inroads on it's
difficult to get data on a number of
these things
um but it but it's uh you know it's a
complicated problem
so in summary
you know housing upgrade is a really
really important problem in in the u.s
and around the world um and housing
upgrades space is right for use of
technology
in a lot of different ways
and the quest for sustainability in
housing can we upgrade houses in a way
that's greener and what makes sense to
do in the most optimal way are big
problems that we're working on
thank you
thank you betsy
uh
our next speaker is woody wider from
vmware
do you see my screen
yes
all right thanks so um
i'm going to present a nugget of a
recent research at vmware i'll tell you
about omni predictors
what they are and what they're good for
uh it's joint work with my colleague
perkshit gopalan from vmware
adam kalai um and omar reingold and
watson were at vmware at the time when
we were working on it and now in
stanford and in usc respectfully so
um
so let's start so
okay so i'll start with just uh
presenting the really
basic learning setting
just to set up a
common framework for what we're talking
about
so
you know the most simple basic uh
learning task we get samples from a
distribution we get labeled examples so
each example consists of a feature space
say the personal information of a person
or the medical info and a label do the
did they test positive or negative for
covid
and our goal is to compute some
hypothesis which is a function from the
feature domain
to say the real numbers it doesn't have
to be real numbers and and this is
supposed to capture some some meaningful
information
we want to
determine whether a person person should
be tested so that would be a
binary value or what dosage of
medication to give and so on
and the question is how do we measure
the quality of the hypothesis that we
computed
and uh the most common framework to do
that is through a loss function that
measures the penalty of
outputting t of x
given that the label was indeed y so you
know a common loss function would be
some p norm of the distance between them
and then we typically think about the
expected loss so we compute the
expectation of the loss given that the
samples are are taken from the
distribution that we trained on
and our goal would be to minimize the
expected loss now we don't minimize over
all possible functions typically that is
not feasible so we also
think about some model families so it is
some family of functions that we care
about and as practitioners we think it's
a relevant family of functions for the
problem at hand
it could be typically dnns of some given
architecture or random forests or many
other options
and then we have in mind
the best hypothesis in that class so c
star would be the one that has the the
lowest cost
um and our goal would be to compute some
hypothesis that is comparable to the
best within that class and it doesn't
have to be actually a member of this
class there are many algorithms
boosting kind of algorithms that are
actually
producing something that is outside that
class but this is how we think about a
very basic learning setting so i've
described something that we've all done
many times
and there is nothing special about it
the point that i want to emphasize is
that in this framework we have to choose
the loss function at the beginning and
that is important because the learned
hypothesis actually depends upon which
loss function we have chosen
the simplest example is uh
you know almost a generate example
imagine that the
model family that we care about is just
constant functions so we want to
approximate the labels by a single
number
and if we minimize the l2 norm then
we're actually pointing at the mean and
if we're minimizing the l1 norm then
we're pointing at the median
and it is impossible to learn the mean
from the median and vice versa
and while this is a very degenerate
example it's possible to uh come up with
more complex and more realistic examples
um and the principle still holds
the learned hypothesis depends upon the
loss function and if we change the loss
function
then it is not clear how to
how to find the new hypothesis that is
optimized for the new loss function
and this comes with some
cost
we don't always know in advance what the
loss function what the corres loss
function is we may want to optimize for
multiple loss functions simultaneously
maybe different loss functions for
different sub populations
uh you know it's uh
some some future data future medical
treatment can show up and we we want uh
now to optimize for a new loss function
that we just didn't think about when we
did the learning
so
in this uh paradigm what what options
can we
what options do we have we can either
retrain with the new loss function or or
live with with our previous one and um
uh popular libraries uh come with uh
dozens of different loss functions kind
of baked in because people want the
flexibility around these things
so um in this work we're trying to
present a new paradigm
for learning that will overcome this
obstacle and we define this object that
we call an omni predictor so an
omnipredictor is a
is a
predictor that um
the idea is that we learn it and then
given a loss function
we can have a
a simple univariate transformation over
the output of this predictor that
depends on the loss function but does
not depend on the data itself
and it would be
competitive with the best
predictor
from that family c
for that loss function l
so in other words what the omnipredictor
does is it extracts all the predictive
power of c for that family of loss
functions l
and then we can learn the predictor once
and uh we compute the actual hypothesis
when the loss function is determined so
once we determine what the loss function
is
there should be a simple way to uh
transform the omni predictor to a
predictor for that specific loss
function
um
now the first thought is why would
something like this even exist
and if you think about it for a minute
then uh um then something like this does
exist and it's actually um maybe not
phrased as an omni predictor but it's
kind of known
uh um as folk or or
or is used in practice and that is the
ground truth predictor so
let's say that we
can really compute the probability of
the label being one given a feature
a feature set x
so if we had that p star x that ground
truth if we were really able to compute
it
then
you can observe that given a point x the
expected contribution of that point x to
the loss function
is actually dependent only on the loss
function
so
if we could have computed uh this uh
ground truth predictor then in fact we
would have had
an omni predictor for essentially for
all loss functions and for all um and
for all
model families
um
and
the main problem here is that the ground
truth predictor typically just cannot be
computed efficiently unless there are
really uh very benign circumstances or
very special uh
and strong assumptions there is no
reason to think that we can per point
per point x compute the ground truth the
real probability that um uh that the
label is one
it does present a very tempting
heuristic to use so we have this family
seed let's say you know deep neural nets
or whatever um and we can compute uh
the best hopefully we can compute the
best predictor from this family
for uh the l2 loss and the reason i
chose the l2 loss is that it is actually
minimized by the actual ground truth so
it is kind of an approximation of the
ground truth with respect to this family
c or so we hope and we can use any
proper loss function so any loss
function that is optimized by the ground
truth's predictions
and now let's use c star
as if it was the ground truth and output
and hypothesis and just hope that it's
good so
so we hope that now this hypothesis
would would be a an omni predictor for
the set see
the problem is that this uh heuristic
even though it's very tempting and it's
actually being used in practice in
various places
does not carry any guarantee and
there are examples that i don't have
time to go through where we can show
that this
heuristic fails
so
in some sense our contribution is to
find out
what predictor actually does work for
this family c um and how to how to
compute it
and in order to describe that i have to
make a very very brief side tour
so there is another property of
predictors that comes from a completely
different
line of thinking that of
of fairness
and that is the properties of
calibration and multi-calibration
so
a predictor is calibrated if it is
correct on expectation
in some sense so let's say we want to
predict the weather for tomorrow so
and we predict in many different cities
and many places and what we want is
let's look at all the places or all the
days where we predicted that rain will
fall 10 with probability 10 percent we
want 10 of these
uh of these days to to be correct for
the rain to actually fall and that
should be true for every prediction that
we give
so a prediction a predictor that has
this property is called calibrated
um and it's clearly a property that we
would like
the thing is that on its own it's very
weak so we want to require something
more from the from a predictor
in particular just giving the
expectation of the population is a
calibrated predictor which is very
benign and very weak from an accuracy
point of view
but this definition could be extended to
the notion of multi-calibration so now
we think of our model family not as just
a set of functions but as a set of
subsets so it's binary functions for now
and and we say that a predictor t is
multi-calibrated with respect to c if it
is calibrated not just for the general
population but for every set from c
separately when uh when we take our
distribution and conditioned it on on
getting samples from that particular set
and the definition could be extended for
c that are real functions um
but it's useful to think uh now as just
a calibration over subsets
and um our theorem
is that
these uh
these multi-calibrated uh predictors are
the right predictors for uh our loss
minimization goal so in fact a
multi-calibrated predictor is an lc omni
predictor so the c is the same c the
same set of models for which we computed
the multi-calibration predictor
and the l the family of loss functions
for which we are an omni predictor is
all convex loss functions um and and we
show that convexity is indeed required
here
and i'd like to point that there are
known algorithms to compute a
multi-calibrated predictor under some
standard assumptions but it is not a
trivial task it it requires something uh
some some form of uh boosting algorithms
that we call boosting by uh branching
programs
so woody i think um we probably need to
wrap up right so this is my last
sentence
i just wanted to say that it's uh it's
good karma that uh
work that was uh um notions that were uh
originally motivated by fairness
actually turned out to be very useful
for um accuracy and loss minimization
purposes and there are a lot of
interesting connections there that we
point out in our paper
so that's the end of my talk thanks
to all our industry partners for this
invigorating session uh i'd like to
invite all of you to join the gather
town uh by following the link in the
chat uh since we are running a little
behind on time we
will resume back uh at 11 15 so it would
be a gathered town session for another
13 minutes or so uh we recommend that
you use your full name on gather town so
that people can recognize you and uh
we'll be muting the zoom microphones uh
during this networking session
just uh
there you go hope you can all see the
link in the chat
see you